Allora, bene, buonasera a tutti.
Buonasera, buonasera a tutti.
Buonasera a tutti.
Contemporaneo di quel salimbene, di quel frasalimbene di cui abbiamo parlato l'altro ieri.
A dire la verità è qualcosa di più di un cavaliere, è un capo di cavalieri, è un gran signore.
Sapete, la maggior parte dei cavalieri sono dei gentiluomini che vivono bene, che hanno terra, servitori, cavalli, ma sono al servizio di qualcuno.
Sono al servizio di un castellano, di un gran signore, il quale è un cavaliere anche lui, ma insomma di un livello un po' superiore.
Joanville è un uomo così, è uno che possiede diversi castelli, quindi possiede una signoria dove lui è il signore, dove lui è l'autorità pubblica.
Lui mantiene l'ordine, riscuote le imposte, amministra la giustizia.
E per di più è anche un grande funzionario del re.
Joanville ha servito per anni il re di Francia come siniscalco di Champagne, cioè amministratore rappresentante del re nella regione di Champagne.
E con tutto questo è un cavaliere.
Essere un cavaliere vuol dire essere stati educati in un certo modo, condividere certi valori.
Che magari sono anche quelli che raccontano i romanzi, i romanzi medievali che tutti abbiamo presenti e che anche loro leggevano.
Dove si dice che il cavaliere deve proteggere le vedove, gli orfani, essere umile e così via.
Poi in realtà i veri valori dei cavalieri sono piuttosto altri.
I valori veri che Joanville condivide con i suoi vassalli sono il valore in guerra, il coraggio fisico dimostrato in battaglia quando si rischia la pelle,
il cameratismo fra compagni d'arme, l'onore.
Detto questo, Joan de Joinville è famoso fra noi storici e io posso parlarvi di lui stasera perché ha fatto una cosa che per i cavalieri era piuttosto insolita.
Ha scritto un libro.
Ha scritto un libro per un motivo preciso.
Lui ha servito, come vi dicevo, a lungo il re di Francia e il re che lui ha maggiormente servito è stato Luigi IX, il santo.
Il grande re di Francia del 200 che è stato protagonista di due crociate, nella seconda c'è poi morto.
Joanville lo ha accompagnato nella prima crociata.
Una spedizione che è partita nel 1248 e è tornata, i pochi che sono tornati, sei anni dopo.
Poi alla seconda crociata del re Joanville non c'è più andato.
Come molti superstiti della prima hanno preferito non andarci, il re c'è andato e c'è morto nel 70.
Joanville è sopravvissuto al suo re per tanti anni.
Quando era già vecchio, siamo già all'inizio del 300, negli stessi anni in cui Dino Compagni, che vi ho raccontato ieri, viveva la politica fiorentina,
in quegli stessi anni nel suo castello di Joanville, lui si rende conto che è uno dei pochi rimasti che si ricordano il re santo.
Nel frattempo Luigi IX è stato fatto santo davvero, l'hanno canonizzato, ormai è ufficialmente un santo.
E allora a Joanville viene voglia di scrivere e qualcuno gli chiede di scrivere.
E lui scrive, scrive questo straordinario libro che dovrebbe essere una vita di Luigi IX e che in realtà sono le memorie di Jean de Joanville,
di questo gran signore francese del suo tempo, dove si racconta soprattutto questa epopea della crociata.
E dunque, e dunque non è soltanto un cavaliere ma è un cavaliere crociato, quello che abbiamo di fronte stasera.
E credo di non stupire nessuno se dico che nella visione del mondo di questo cavaliere crociato,
che per di più sta ricordando i tempi della crociata proprio,
ebbene in questa visione del mondo la religione ha un posto centrale.
Qui non rimane deluso chi ha in mente diciamo un medioevo dominato dalla religione.
È vero che per molti, quasi tutti, la religione era comunque una dimensione vissuta con un'intensità
che oggi, insomma, pochi si immaginano.
Non parlo solo di Luigi IX che infatti è stato fatto santo.
Io pensavo prima di raccontarvi, di farvi l'elenco di tutte le messe e gli uffici divini
che Luigi IX sentiva ogni giorno della sua vita.
Poi ho pensato che perdevamo troppo tempo a fare questo lungo elenco,
ma il re sentiva diverse messe e parecchi uffici divini cantati e no ogni giorno.
Era un santo, Joanville che è un cavaliere qualunque, un signore qualunque,
una messa al giorno però la sente.
La giornata di un cristiano e la giornata di un cavaliere comincia con la messa.
E la religione è sempre presente.
C'è una familiarità spontanea con le cose della religione che è caratteristica di questa gente.
Entravano i cani in chiesa nel medioevo quindi noi qui non ci facciamo certo spaventare.
Racconto un aneddoto che rende l'idea di come loro ragionavano.
Stanno tornando dalla crociata dopo essere stati fuori sei anni
e aver visto morire la maggior parte dei loro amici.
Tornando dalla crociata che è stata in Egitto e loro tornano per mare,
a un certo punto fanno scalo a Lampedusa, come capita a quelli che partono dall'Egitto e vanno per mare naturalmente.
Fanno scalo a Lampedusa che trovano deserta, non ci vive nessuno.
Però ci sono gli avanzi, anzi c'è ancora un eremitaggio.
Loro capiscono subito che è un eremitaggio.
Si vede è un eremitaggio, è una casetta isolata col suo orto, col suo giardino,
dove ci sono dei fichi, delle viti, degli olivi e poi ha una cappella, un oratorio.
Quello che fa capire che è un eremitaggio.
C'è un oratorio imbiancato a calce con un crocifisso
e non c'è nessuno.
Nella stanza accanto ci sono due scheletri.
Ci sono due morti che sono stati ricomposti dopo la morte e lasciati lì
e sono evidentemente gli eremiti che hanno vissuto in quel luogo.
Loro sono tutti commossi, poi hanno fatto acqua,
se ne tornano alle galere per ripartire.
Al momento di ripartire si accorgono che manca un marinaio.
Manca un marinaio, aspetta, aspetta, non torna.
Finalmente quelli che lo conoscono dicono
ma secondo noi si è fermato qua per fare l'eremita a lui.
C'è stata questa occasione,
quello che fino a un momento fa
chissà cos'altro pensava di fare della sua vita
e invece è rimasto così colpito
dalla scoperta di questo eremitaggio deserto, abbandonato,
da decidere di fare l'eremita.
E questa cosa sembra naturale a tutti.
Tutti dicono, è certo, evidentemente è così.
Gli lasciano delle casse di biscotto sulla spiaggia
in modo che possa nutrirsi per un po'
e poi arriverà qualche altra nave
e continuerà a mantenere l'eremita e ripartono.
E per loro è una vicenda normale.
Così come è normale che avvengano i miracoli.
Voi sapete, i miracoli se uno ci crede avvengono.
Allora ci credevano praticamente tutti
e quindi avvenivano.
Era facile essere sicuri di aver assistito a un miracolo.
E aver assistito a un miracolo era una cosa importante
che ti restava in pressa, che ti portavi dietro.
Specialmente durante una crociata catastrofica
come quella di San Luigi, di miracoli.
Ce ne vogliono tanti per aiutarli a tornare a casa, i superstiti.
Joinville ha assistito personalmente a un miracolo.
Sempre durante il viaggio, di ritorno,
a un certo punto dalla nave davanti alla sua,
uno si è arrampicato da qualche parte
per fare qualche lavoro sulla nave,
è caduto in acqua.
E Joinville dice, noi dalla nave dietro
vedevamo questa cosa in acqua.
Ma era immobile, tanto che abbiamo pensato
che fosse un pacco, un mobile,
qualcosa che era caduto lì,
un oggetto che era caduto in mare.
Comunque mettiamo in mare la barca
per andarlo a recuperare,
si scopre che è un uomo, un marinaio.
E vivo e vegeto sta benissimo.
E gli chiediamo, ma perché non nuotavi,
non cercavi di agitarti, di chiamare?
E il marinaio, dice Joinville,
che l'ha sentito con le sue orecchie,
ha detto, ma non ce n'era mica bisogno.
Perché quando mi son sentito
che cadevo in mare,
ho invocato la vergine di Vauvert.
E la vergine di Vauvert mi è apparsa
e mi ha tenuto su.
E io mi son sentito che mi teneva su.
E mi teneva a galla.
Perciò stavo tranquillo.
E Joinville ha assistito
con i suoi occhi a un miracolo.
Lo racconta così, en passant.
Potrebbe essere finita qua.
Invece, nella frase dopo dice,
e io l'ho fatto dipingere
nella cappella di Joinville.
è nelle vetrate della chiesa di Blecourt,
che è l'altro villaggio che gli appartiene.
Questo vuol dire che anche se lui adesso
non ci insiste,
perché averlo sentito un miracolo
può capitare a tutti, insomma.
Però poi quando ti capita davvero a te,
è una cosa che te la senti dentro.
E lui che è il signore del villaggio,
lo fa frescare nella chiesa,
lo fa mettere nelle vetrate e così via.
Ecco, questo è il mondo
in cui loro vivono
dal punto di vista religioso,
dove la religione
è un grande collante
che accomuna tutti
ed è sentita con estrema,
come dire,
con grande fervore
e grande semplicità anche.
Anche troppa semplicità,
certe volte.
Joinville racconta un episodio
con grande approvazione,
devo dire.
E c'è stato una volta,
mi hanno raccontato,
di recente,
al monastero di Cluny,
sapete Cluny in Borgogna,
grande monastero benedettino,
a monastero di Cluny
avevano organizzato
una grande disputa
di chierici
e di ebrei.
Le dispute erano una cosa,
forse l'ho già accennato
parlandone di Frassalimbene,
le dispute intellettuali,
pubbliche,
erano una cosa
che piaceva molto
ai chierici,
agli uomini di chiesa
del Medioevo.
Gli piaceva questa occasione
di dimostrare
quanti erano bravi
affrontando degli avversari,
discutendo con loro.
I loro fratelli
che non si erano fatti preti,
facevano i tornei
e ogni giorno
dimostravano
di essere i più bravi
sconfiggendo un avversario.
Anche agli ecclesiastici
piaceva farlo.
Dunque,
al monastero di Cluny
si organizza
una disputa teologica
fra dei chierici
e dei rabbini
e c'era lì,
dice Joanville,
mi hanno raccontato,
un vecchio cavaliere
che viveva lì
al monastero,
l'abate lo manteneva
per carità.
Capitava spesso
che un cavaliere
che aveva passato la vita
a combattere,
a menare le mani,
in vecchiaia,
intanto non ne poteva più fisicamente
e magari ne aveva anche abbastanza
di quella vita,
spesso in vecchiaia
andavano a vivere in monastero.
Chi aveva qualcosa
regalava i suoi beni
al monastero,
chi non aveva niente
poteva anche essere accolto
per carità
e passavano gli ultimi anni
di vita in monastero.
Allora,
dice Joanville,
mi hanno raccontato
che al momento in cui doveva
cominciare la disputa
questo cavaliere
si è fatto avanti
e ha chiesto di poter essere
il primo
a disputare con il rabbino.
E l'abate
non è che fosse tanto contento,
però
l'altro insisteva
e ha dovuto dargli d'accordo
comincia tu.
Allora il cavaliere
appoggiato alla sua gruccia
molto cortesemente
chiede al rabbino
maestro
ma voi ci credete
alla Vergine Maria
che ha partorito
nostro Signore
il Dio
ed è rimasta vergine?
E il rabbino
dice Joanville
gli rispose
che loro non ci credevano
neanche un po'
e il cavaliere rispose
fate molto male
e alzò la gruccia
e assestò una gran botta
sulla testa del rabbino
e gli ebrei
si portarono via
il rabbino
e la disputa
finì lì
e Joanville
ne ha parlato
col santo re Luigi
di questa cosa
e tutti e due
si sono trovati d'accordo
che il cavaliere
ha fatto benissimo
perché
disputare
con i miscredenti
insomma
è già pericoloso
però lo possono fare
i dotti sapienti
che riescono
a tenergli testa
perché se va male
se vincono gli ebrei
in una disputa pubblica
ecco
ci può essere anche
qualche bravo cristiano
che ha le idee
confuse a quel punto
quindi bisogna stare attenti
i laici
in queste cose
non si devono mescolare
i laici
gli dice il santo re
quando sentono
parlare male
della fede cristiana
devono tirar fuori
la spada
dunque
questa fede
così spontanea
così irruente
anche
così violenta
così intensa
certe volte
ecco
non vi stupirete
se vi dico
che è anche
una fede
molto attaccata
alle forme
molto formalistica
perché appunto
una fede ingenua
vuole anche dire
che insomma
io ci tengo
a fare le cose giuste
a rispettare
il digiuno del venerdì
il digiuno della quaresima
e se queste cose
non le rispetto
mi sento veramente male
sono cose che
insomma
nel cristianesimo di oggi
hanno perso importanza
e invece
allora
il cristiano
si senteva
potentemente
obbligato
a rispettare
tutte queste cose
è successo proprio
a Joinville
di sperimentarlo
di persona
siamo durante
la crociata
anzi
verso la fine
della crociata
che è già finita
malissimo
i turchi
hanno vinto
hanno massacrato
mezzo esercito
crociato
hanno catturato
tutti gli altri
sono scene
che Joinville
tra l'altro
descrive
con una potenza
straordinaria
ecco questi momenti
di sfacelo
di fuga
di caos
questi che si arrendono
e
arrendersi
è un azzardo
perché non sai
nelle mani di chi finisci
e i turchi
i saraceni
è difficile prevedere
cosa faranno
ci sono quelli
che
quando vedono
dei prigionieri
un po' malandati
malati
eccetera
una botta in testa
è giù in mare
e invece ci sono quelli
che trattano
molto cortesemente
i prigionieri
poi comunque
il re e i gran signori
vengono sempre trattati
molto cortesemente
quello va da sé
anche perché
pagheranno un grosso riscatto
per essere liberati
ma poi comunque
i re e i gran signori
cristiani o musulmani
si capiscono
fanno parte dello stesso mondo
hanno tanti argomenti in comune
come vedremo subito
dunque le cose
sono già più o meno finite
giovanville
giovanville è prigioniero
ed è a pranzo
con un emiro
che l'ha invitato a pranzo
l'emiro l'ha invitato a pranzo
e stanno chiacchierando
con l'interprete
si capisce
e stanno chiacchierando
allegramente
dei rispettivi alberi genealogici
e di conoscenze comuni
perché l'emiro
è molto interessato
all'imperatore Federico II
viene fuori
che giovanville
è parente
dell'imperatore Federico II
sono lì
che stanno confrontando
appunto
le conoscenze
e gli antenati
e mangiano
a un certo punto
capita lì
un altro crociato prigioniero
un borghese francese
dice giovanville
mi vede
e mi dice
ma Messere
ma che cosa fate?
Giulia dice
ma perché scusa
cosa sto facendo?
ma per l'amor di Dio
Messere
state mangiando carne di venerdì
giovanville salta in piedi
allontana la scodella
orripilato
perché
voi capite
nel caos
la battaglia
la cattura
tutto
si era scordato
che giorno era
era venerdì
e stava mangiando carne
l'emiro
che assiste a questa scena
gli fa chiedere
dall'interprete
cosa è successo
giovanville
glielo spiega
e il musulmano
gli dice
ma sta tranquillo
che Dio
non può avercela con te
non l'hai mica fatto apposta
giovanville però
ci sta male
di aver fatto questa cosa
appena può
va a consultare
il legato papale
presso l'esercito crociato
quindi
un alto prelato
gli racconta tutto
l'alto prelato
gli dice
la stessa cosa
che gli ha detto
il musulmano
cioè
Dio non può avercela con te
non l'hai fatto apposta
non preoccuparti
giovanville non ci crede
si sente addosso
questa cosa
dice ho cominciato
a digiunare a pane e acqua
tutti i venerdì
per liberarmi
per purificarmi
da questa cosa
che avevo fatto
quindi le forme
sono importanti
le forme sono importanti
non bisogna trasgredirle
ed è una religiosità
che pur essendolo
abbiamo visto
intensissima
e spontanea
è anche attaccatissima
al rispetto
delle regole formali
delle parole
che si pronunciano
per esempio
è un mondo curioso
questo perché
tutti hanno continuamente
in bocca
Dio e il diavolo
tutti continuamente
tutti giurano
quando si deve dire qualcosa
tutti dicono
per Dio
in nome di Dio
per la testa di Dio
per le piaghe di Dio
ognuno ha il suo modo
di giurare
Juenville spesso lo nota
ci sono dei gran signori
che hanno un modo
particolare di giurare
c'è uno che giura
per la cuffia di Dio
continuamente
e dall'altra dice
tutti hanno sempre
in bocca il diavolo
va al diavolo
ti porti il diavolo
e questa dice
Juenville
è una cosa brutta
è una delle tragedie
del nostro rebel regno
di Francia
il santo re Luigi
lui non menzionava mai
né Dio né il diavolo
non ho mai sentito
dire queste cose
invece
noi lo facciamo
e menzionare Dio
in questo modo
in realtà non è la cosa
più grave
è grave menzionare il diavolo
infatti Juenville dice
io a casa mia
ho stabilito una regola
chiunque gli scappa di bocca
di menzionare il diavolo
o paga pegno
o fa penitenza
e fra i miei servi
è praticamente sparita
questa brutta abitudine
menzionare Dio
invece va bene
uno per rafforzare
le sue affermazioni
chiama Dio a testimone
anche lui l'ha fatto
e però ci si mette nei guai
certe volte
racconta Juenville
sempre durante la crociata
come il grosso
delle cose che vi racconto
stasera
i crociati si stavano
spostando
spostavano l'accampamento
ogni sera mettevano le tende
in un posto nuovo
una sera dice
è venuto uno dei miei cavalieri
quello che aveva scelto
il posto per la tenda
quella sera
e mi dice
si re
si diceva si re i signori
anche non soltanto i re
in francese antico
si re
stasera
vi ho alloggiato meglio
di ieri sera
il cavaliere
che aveva scelto il posto
per la tenda
ieri sera
sente questo
salta su
lo prende per i capelli
e gli fa
come osi parlare
di qualcosa che faccio io
ora questa è una grandissima
scortesia
davanti al signore
accapigliarsi
fra cavalieri
in questo modo
è il massimo
della villania
della maleducazione
Juenville non ci vede più
e dice
così come
Dio mi aiuti
tu non entrerai mai più
in casa mia
ti licenzio
non sarai mai più
uno dei miei cavalieri
questo se ne va piangendo
poi torna
lo implora
di perdonarlo
fa venire gli amici
che gli dicono
ma su
per una cosa così
e Juenville dice
beh
io per me
però ho giurato
ho detto
così come Dio mi aiuti
tu non entrerai più
in casa mia
adesso non posso mica
farti rientrare
come se niente fosse
se il legato papale
mi scioglie
dal mio giuramento
io sono contentissimo
di riprenderti
vanno dal legato papale
gli spiegano la cosa
e il legato papale
dice
mi dispiace
ma il giuramento
questo è un giuramento valido
c'erano dei motivi
io non lo posso mica
sciogliere così
come niente fosse
non si può
e dice
Juenville
così ho imparato
bisogna stare attenti
a quel che si dice
perché non l'ha più ripreso
il suo cavaliere
dopo questa vicenda
un altro aspetto
che colpisce
molto
di questa religiosità
così come l'esprime
Juenville
ma certamente
è condiviso
da tanti
è un altro aspetto
di concretezza
dicevo prima
che i miracoli avvengono
che si chiama
continuamente
Dio a testimone
di quello che succede
c'è qualcosa di più
ci si aspetta
continuamente
di essere aiutati
da Dio
dalla Vergine
dai Santi
ci si aspetta
continuamente
che mentre uno
attraverso un guaio
o una difficoltà
invocando Dio
Dio ti aiuta
e quando sei in pericolo
e rischi la pelle
in battaglia
invochi Dio
e Dio ti aiuta
è per questo
che noi serviamo Dio
dice
Juenville
durante la crociata
gli hanno spiegato
che molti musulmani
i beduini
dice lui in particolare
lui ha raccontato così
dice i beduini
hanno una credenza
molto strana
hanno la credenza
che l'uomo
porta scritte
in fronte alla sua morte
e che quindi
può morire
soltanto nel giorno stabilito
lo sapete
si usa a dire
questa cosa
del fatalismo musulmano
per cui
ogni uomo
ha già il giorno
prestabilito
della sua morte
e Juenville trova
che questa è un'idea assurda
perché se uno
ha già il giorno
stabilito
della sua morte
è come dire
che Dio
non ti può aiutare
per cambiare le cose
che Dio
non ti può aiutare
quando sei lì
che rischi la pelle
in battaglia
e lo invochi
e non serve a niente
invocarlo
perché tanto
è già tutto deciso
e Juenville dice
ma questa è una cosa
ridicola
se fosse davvero così
e questa è la cosa
che mi ha colpito di più
la cosa più interessante
la conclusione
più interessante
che lui ricava
da questa cosa
dice se fosse davvero così
ma sarebbero scemi
quelli che servono Dio
se noi non credessimo
che abbia il potere
di allungarci la vita
e di aiutarci
nelle difficoltà
è per quello
che lo serviamo
e a lui sembra
perfettamente ovvio
c'è un contratto
con Dio
e questa è
la logica
dopodiché
forse cominciate
già a intravedere
quella che a me
sembra una
come dire
una grossa contraddizione
di questa religiosità
che da un lato
è così calda
è così sincera
e però
non esclude affatto
l'attaccamento
come dire
all'interesse concreto
ai vantaggi concreti
all'aiuto
che si spera
di ottenere
certo
servire Dio
vuol dire
vuol dire fare
delle rinunce
anche delle rinunce
pesanti
certe volte
e chi lo può sapere
meglio di Joanville
che ha passato
sei anni
alla crociata
quando lui racconta
la partenza
per la crociata
lo dice in poche parole
sono partito
il re Luigi
quando è partito
lo raccontavo
l'altro ieri sera
ha attraversato
metà del suo regno
a piedi
vestito da pellegrino
col bastone
la bisaccia
Joanville non ha fatto
la stessa cosa
ma anche lui
allontanandosi
del suo castello
di Joanville
ha fatto il giro
delle chiese
dei dintorni
a piedi
umilmente
col bastone
da pellegrino
prima di allontanarsi
definitivamente
e dice
mentre facevo il giro
non mi son mai
voltato indietro
a guardare
verso Joanville
perché non volevo
che mi venisse addosso
la pena
del bel castello
che stavo lasciando
di mia moglie
e dei miei figli
quindi
di rinuncia
se ne fanno
dopo quella partenza
lui sta via sei anni
prima di rivedere
la moglie e i figli
e il castello
di Joanville
e però
di rinuncia
se ne fanno
ma il buon senso
si tiene sempre presente
non si va
alla crociata
per il gusto
di farsi ammazzare
anzi
si va alla crociata
sperando alla fine
di salvare la pelle
e tornare indietro
non sono dei martiri
fanatici
questi crociati
questi cavalieri
crociati
e la cosa viene fuori
con assoluta evidenza
proprio
nel momento
in cui
i crociati
vengono sbaragliati
e i turchi
cominciano a catturarli
Joanville in quel momento
è su una nave
loro stavano cercando
di scampare
a bordo di queste navi
però
gli arrivano addosso
le galere dei saraceni
circondano la sua galera
lui è su questa nave
con i suoi cavalieri
con tutti i suoi domestici
tutta la sua gente
gli arrivano addosso
i saraceni
si preparano
a bordare la galera
e Joanville dice
noi ci siamo chiesti
che facciamo adesso
e ci siamo trovati
tutti d'accordo
ci arrendiamo
non c'è assolutamente
niente da fare
ma uno dei miei domestici
dice
un cantiniere
ha alzato la mano
ha detto
io non sono d'accordo
con questa decisione
e tu che cosa consigli
io dico
di farci ammazzare tutti
così andremo dritti
in paradiso
e questo è veramente
quel medioevo
come noi in fondo
ce l'aspettiamo
è interessante
che sia
non un nobile cavaliere
ma uno qualunque
che ha questa idea
siamo qua
andiamo fino in fondo
siamo coerenti
fino al martirio
questo è il medioevo
che ci aspettiamo
salvo che è soltanto lui
che lo dice
Joanville liquida
la questione
con una frasetta
ma noi non gli abbiamo
mica dato retta
e infatti
si arrendono
e la scampano
in gran parte
buon senso
religiosità
impegni religiosi
mantenere la parola
non è facile
essere coerenti
in questo campo
il buon re Luigi
era un santo
anche perché lui
la parola
la manteneva sempre
perfino con i saraceni
che è una cosa
che a Joanville
colpisce abbastanza
perché insomma
mantenere la parola
certo
ma con quelli
e invece è successo
l'ha visto lui
dopo la prigionia
stanno pagando
il riscatto
ci sono stati
lunghi negoziati
con i saraceni
che li hanno catturati
alla fine hanno stabilito
una grossissima somma
200.000 lire tornesi
un'enorme somma
per liberare il re
e i gran signori
e a questo punto
sono venuti i soldi
dalla Francia
sono arrivati
giorni e giorni
per contarli
per consegnarli
quando hanno quasi finito
uno dei cavalieri
del re
Messer Philippe de Nemours
arriva tutto allegro
e dice
sì re
li abbiamo imbrogliati
gli abbiamo dato
10.000 lire di meno
e non se ne sono accorti
sono tutti contenti
il re
non è contento per niente
è un santo
queste cose
lui non le fa
è imbronciato
e dice
ma io ho
dato la mia parola
di pagare 200.000 lire
e paghiamo 200.000 lire
a questo punto
succede la seguente commedia
Joanville
che è presente
pesta il piede
a Messer Philippe de Nemours
perché stia zitto
e dice
ma no
si re scherzava
non è mica vero
imbrogliare i saraceni
chi ci riesce
sanno tutti
che i saraceni
sono bravissimi
a contare
e Messer Philippe de Nemours
che ha mangiato la foglia
dice
sì sì è vero
è vero
scherzavo
ma il re
non si fa bindolare
rimane di pessimo umore
dice
se hai scherzato
era uno scherzo stupido
e io adesso vado a controllare
perché voglio essere sicuro
che abbiamo pagato tutto
perché questo peso
non me lo porto dietro
ecco non era facilissimo
convivere con questo re
come vedete
io ho cominciato raccontandovi
di un cavaliere crociato
che ha una profonda religiosità
però un conto
è avere una profonda religiosità
e un conto
è dover vivere
con un re santo
che le cose
le spinge
le spinge all'estremo
oltretutto
quando Joinville
scrive da vecchio
è ormai ufficiale
il re è santo
è stato canonizzato
ma quando avvenivano
queste cose
che erano giovani
tutti e due
sì il re aveva già
questa fama
di essere santo
ma insomma
capite la differenza
Joinville lo ammirava molto
lo amava molto
però lavorarci insieme
non era facile
proprio per niente
le occasioni di scontro
c'erano continuamente
per fortuna
c'era di buono questo
che il re
aveva il senso
dell'umorismo
e stava allo scherzo
perché più di una volta
Joinville
se le lasciate scappare grosse
una volta è capitato
che nell'accampamento
dei crociati
momento di tregua
con i saraceni
tutti tranquilli
arrivano dei pellegrini
dei cristiani d'oriente
armeni
che stanno andando
il pellegrinaggio
a Gerusalemme
col permesso dei saraceni
attraversano il campo crociato
e poi cominciano
a informarsi
e vanno anche a chiedere
a Joinville
gli mandano l'interprete
dicendo
ma noi abbiamo saputo
che qui nel campo
c'è il re santo
possiamo vedere il re santo
Joinville
sia che si fosse svegliato male
quel mattino
sia che
questa cosa che il re
era un santo
non gli era ancora
proprio ben entrato in testa
ecco
va dal re
sono amici
lui
l'altro è il re
lui è un suo collaboratore
ma sono in rapporti
molto stretti
va dal re
lo trova
dice
seduto
sotto la sua tenda
sulla sabbia
con neanche un tappeto
sotto
e gli dice
si re
lì fuori c'è della gente
che dice che vuole vedere il santo
ma io non ho mica voglia
di baciare le vostre ossa
baciare le vostre ossa
è una cosa che un
un uomo del medioevo
avrebbe capito subito
cosa voleva dire
le ossa dei santi
le reliquie
i santi normalmente
non sono vivi
la grande maggioranza
dei santi
sono morti
e noi il rapporto
che abbiamo con loro
è perché abbiamo
le loro reliquie
che per la gente
del medioevo
sono importantissime
e le reliquie
sono venerate
baciate
certo
però andare a dire
al re
non è ancora ora
di baciare le tue ossa
non è proprio
un modo gentile
di mettere la cosa
per fortuna
il re si mette a ridere
un'altra volta
succede
che c'è una questione
di soldi
e forse qui
dovrei fare una parentesi
perché io sto parlando
di cavalieri crociati
poi fra poco
parleremo di valore
guerriero
di cortesia
di ideali cavallereschi
finora stiamo parlando
di fede religiosa
di crociate
di martirio
ecco
i soldi
sembrerebbe
che non dovessero
entrarci niente
in tutto questo
errore
i soldi
c'entrano moltissimo
una crociata
costa un sacco di soldi
ed è una grande impresa
che va pianificata
e la primissima cosa
è trovare i soldi
poi quando ci sono i soldi
si può cominciare
a organizzare l'esercito
assumere cavalieri
ruolare gente
fabbricare le na
e così via
questo costa carissimo
i soldi
c'entrano dappertutto
un gruppo di cavalieri
che parte per la crociata
al seguito di un signore
nove volte su dieci
sono stati assunti
regolarmente
con regolare contratto
e pagati
è vero che ci sarebbe
il sistema feudale
ogni signore
ha i suoi vassalli
che dovrebbero
prestare servizio
ma quelle sono cose vecchie
nessuno più
presta servizio gratis
ecco
tanto meno
andare lontano
i vassalli stessi
se accompagnano il signore
in un'impresa pericolosa
come la crociata
vogliono essere pagati
poi se uno riesce
a mettere insieme
un gruppetto
fatto tutto
di suoi vassalli
di suoi parenti
allora bene
Joinville a un certo punto
lo dice durante un combattimento
una squadra di cavalieri
che ha combattuto
particolarmente bene
dice beh
quelli lì
erano tutti vassalli
o parenti del loro signore
però questo è una casa
ormai eccezionale
di solito i cavalieri
uno li ha assunti
e li licenzia
come Joinville
ha licenziato
quel tale scortese
che poi se ne è pentito
ecco
dunque devi pagarli
e Joinville ci racconta
dettagliatamente
quanti soldi
guadagnava lui
dalle sue terre
quando è partito
per la crociata
quanto ha speso
per assumere
i suoi dieci cavalieri
dopodiché
siccome la crociata
la organizza il re
un gran signore
come Joinville
che ha i suoi dieci cavalieri
ed è già un'unità
di una certa rilevanza
perché un cavaliere
armato
con l'armatura
i suoi cavalli
i suoi domestici
averne dieci
è già una cosa
Joinville va dal re
e il re
a sua volta
lo assume
quindi gli paga
una certa somma
per essere accompagnato
da lui
e dai suoi cavalieri
i soldi
c'entrano in tutto
chiusa la parentesi
c'è stata una grana
a un certo punto
perché il periodo
contrattato
tra Joinville
e il re
era finito
bisognava rifare
il contratto
ed era un momento
di difficoltà
il re era rimasto
senza un soldo
Joinville
invece
era abbastanza
ben messo
a mezzi
perciò decide
di fare lo splendido
come dicono
i nostri ragazzi
oggi
va dal re
gli dice
sarebbe ora
di rifare il contratto
io sono pronto
a prestare servizio
con i miei cavalieri
e il re dice
sono contentissimo
quanto volete
non chiedete troppo
perché siamo messi
molto male
e Joinville gli dice
maestà
no maestà
non si diceva ancora
sire
dicono
a me mi va bene
fare un patto
facciamo questo accordo
invece di pagarmi
facciamo l'accordo
che per tutti questi sei mesi
che rimango al vostro servizio
con i miei cavalieri
non vi arrabbierete mai con me
perché voi
ogni volta che uno
vi viene a chiedere qualcosa
vi arrabbiate
e io sono stanco
di sentire il re
che si arrabbia con me
facciamo questo patto
se mi promettete
di non arrabbiarvi più
per sei mesi
io presto servizio gratis
cioè li pago io
i cavalieri
e anche stavolta
il re si mette a ridere
e finisce bene
per fortuna
anzi
è felice il re
di questo bel gesto
cavalleresco
che ha fatto
il sire di Joinville
va subito a raccontarlo a tutti
e qui Joinville
ha mostrato effettivamente
che lui non è un mercante
lui è un nobile cavaliere
i soldi sa che contano
contano parecchio
gli importa averne
li conta anche lui
ma all'occasione
si fa il grande gesto
perché il nobile appunto
non è un mercante
non sta sempre
soltanto a calcolare
dunque si diceva
che vivere
al fianco di San Luigi
non è facilissimo
anche perché
il santo
il santo stesso
non si rende mica conto
certe volte
che lui è un santo
e non può pretendere
dagli altri
le stesse cose
che fa lui
San Luigi è uno
che la sua santità
la dimostra continuamente
la gente è sbalordita
a un certo punto
fuori dall'accampamento
dei crociati
sono rimasti
dei cadaveri
di morti
dell'ultima battaglia
si sono dimenticati
di seppellirli
è passato qualche giorno
sono in Africa
d'estate
nessuno ha più voglia
di andarli a seppellire
non ci va nessuno
un bel pomeriggio
vedono il re
che esce dalla tenda
si rimbocca le maniche
e va lui
personalmente
a cominciare
a seppellire
questi cadaveri
allora si vergognano tutti
ma morire
e accorrono
in più di un'occasione
consigliano al re
di salvarsi
perché le cose
stanno andando male
in questa crociata
e di tornare a casa
e il re
dice
ma abbiamo i mezzi
per riportare indietro tutti
in questo momento
i mezzi per riportare indietro tutti
non ci sono
ma quello che conta
più di tutti
è il re
e noi
bisogna salvare il re
e Luigi risponde
io vedo qui
intorno tutta questa gente
e tutti quanti
amano la loro vita
quanto io amo la mia
e perciò io
non me ne andrò
lasciandoli qua
a perdizione
dove la cosa interessante
non è soltanto
come dire
questo tratto
che non tutti i re
dell'epoca
avrebbero condiviso
e di preoccuparsi
di salvare anche
la povera gente
ma è il fatto che il re
la sua vita la ama
gli sembra ovvio dirlo
io l'amo
è come la mia vita
però so che l'amano
anche gli altri
dopodiché dicevo
viverci vicino
non è facile
e gli episodi
che racconta
Joanneville
sono tanti
da questo punto di vista
un bel momento
ci sono lui e il re
che chiacchierano
e al re viene in mente
di porgli una domanda
dice
Sire di Joanneville
una domanda
un quesito
ditemi un po'
preferireste
essere lebroso
o aver commesso
un peccato mortale
e Joanneville
gli risponde
immediatamente
ma io preferirei
averne fatti
trenta di peccati mortali
piuttosto che
essere lebroso
e si prende
una lavata di capo
memorabile
un'altra volta
giovedì santo
il re
lava i piedi
ai poveri
in memoria
di quel che fece
nostro signore
e poi
va da Joanneville
e gli dice
sai è una gran bella cosa
questo fatto
lavare i piedi
ai poveri
dovreste farlo
anche voi
perché non lavate
i piedi ai poveri
il giovedì santo
Joanneville
e Joanneville
gli risponde
ma per la fede
che devo a Dio
i piedi
di quei villani
io non li lavo
e anche stavolta
il re ci rimane male
naturalmente
ma appunto
Joanneville è uno
che le dice le cose
le dice quando
gli vengono in mente
non si preoccupa
e su questo
non laverò i piedi
di questi villani
possiamo forse
lasciare da parte
la dimensione religiosa
che ci ha occupati
anche fin troppo a lungo
finora
ma dopo tutto questo
è un crociato
e parlare
dell'altra dimensione
assolutamente centrale
della vita
e della mentalità
di questi
di questi cavalieri
cioè
questa mentalità
aristocratica
per cui
la società
è divisa
e ci sono
i gentiluomini
i nobili
i cavalieri
i signori
e loro
sono il meglio
che c'è
e poi ci sono
i villani
e sono tutti
gli altri
sono quelli
che lavorano
sono tutti i villani
non soltanto i contadini
che zappano nel campo
ma anche i mercanti
i finanzieri
quelli che hanno fatto
magari anche i soldi
e ne hanno magari
di soldi tanti
magari più dei cavalieri
comincia questo fenomeno
è una cosa ignobile
perché i villani
si sa
sono gente ignobile
le uniche persone
per bene
sono i nobili
sono i gentiluomini
sono i cavalieri
questa è una cosa
che è radicata
profondissimamente
proprio come un automatismo
nella testa
di quelli come
Joanville
e gli episodi
di questo genere
sono innumerevoli
qui si trova
alla corte del re
arriva
gli viene incontro
il cappellano del re
mastro
Robert de Sorbon
che sarà poi famoso
perché fonderà
il collegio
della Sorbona
in cui poi avrà sede
l'università di Parigi
mastro Robert de Sorbon
vede entrare a corte
Joanville
gli va incontro
lo prende per la falda
dell'abito
e lo tira fino dal re
e Joanville
è piuttosto stupito
cosa diavolo sta succedendo
cosa diavolo appunto
perché ogni tanto scappa
e allora
mastro Robert de Sorbon
chiama il re
gli dice
io qui
mi lamento
del sire di Joanville
che viene a corte
vestito così
di pelliccia
e tessuti preziosi
quando il re
guardate un po'
non è vestito così bene
quanto voi
quella era ancora
un'epoca
l'ho già detto altre volte
relativamente semplice
relativamente modesta
il lusso non era ancora tale
neanche nelle corte
il re
era vestito di tessuto normale
Joanville è vestito di pelliccia
si sente dire questa cosa
e reagisce
con una durezza estrema
cioè gli dice
mastro Robert
quest'abito che io porto
me l'ha lasciato in eredità
mio padre
è l'abito che può portare
chi viene da una famiglia
come la mia
io sono vestito
come era vestito mio padre
non si può dire
la stessa cosa di voi
perché guardatevi un po'
anche voi siete vestiti
di tessuti preziosi
e tutti sanno
che vostro padre
era un villano qualunque
ed è vero
Robert de Sorbonne
è uno dei tanti
che attraverso la chiesa
fanno carriera
venendo dal basso
c'è questa scena
spiacevolissima
a corte
il re si intromette
difende Robert de Sorbonne
mette fine alla cosa
e poi però c'è una coda
perché poi più tardi
il re va a prendere
Joinville
e gli dice
sire di Joinville
io mi devo scusare
perché ho difeso
mastro Robert
e non se lo meritava
perché avevate ragione voi
però l'ho visto
talmente confuso
talmente umiliato
che non me la son sentita
di lasciarlo così
in difficoltà
però avevate ragione voi
perché i nobili
vanno vestiti di pelliccia
perché così andavano vestiti
i loro padri
i loro nonni
e il villano rifatto
il parvenu
che ha appena fatto i soldi
non deve permettersi
di mettersi al loro livello
è una mentalità
che durerà per secoli
detto fra parentesi
e si arriverà
non dico alla rivoluzione francese
ma addirittura
al pieno ottocento
perché cominci a tramontare
nella nobiltà europea
questa idea
di essere
un ceto
intrinsecamente
superiore
e che tutti gli altri
siano gente
che val poco
eppure
Gioanville lo sa
lo dicevo prima
comincia a esserci qualcuno
di questi villani rifatti
che ha fatto talmente
tanti soldi
che sono diventati
persone importanti
comprano castelli
occupano posizioni
importanti a corte
e questa è una cosa
difficile da accettare
non c'è niente di più divertente
che vederli rimessi
al loro posto
questi villani
che hanno fatto carriera
alla corte
del conte di Champagno
racconta Gioanville
c'era un borghese
ricchissimo
Herteau de Nogin
aveva fatto
un sacco di soldi
era un uomo importante
un giorno
alla corte
del conte di Champagne
arriva un povero
cavaliere
senza mezzi
che si rivolge
al conte
supplicandolo
di regalargli qualcosa
per poter fare
la dote
alle sue figlie
Herteau de Nogin
che è lì
gli dice
ma sire cavaliere
cosa venite a chiedere
soldi
un regalo al conte
il conte ha già regalato
fin troppo
non ha più niente da regalare
e lo manda via
in malo modo
il conte è lì
ha sentito tutto
interviene immediatamente
si rivolge
al gran borghese
Herteau de Nogin
e gli dice
ma signor Villano
come vi permettete
di dire che non ho più
niente da regalare
ce lo si qualcosa
da regalare
o voi
lo afferra
per l'abito
e lo sbatte
tra le mani del cavalier
dicendo
te lo consegno
lascialo andare
solo quando avrà pagato
un riscatto
come si fa in guerra
che si catturano i prigionieri
e i prigionieri
vengono liberati
dopo aver negoziato
un riscatto
e questa storia
di come Herteau de Nogin
è stato rimesso
al suo posto
ovviamente
fa il giro
delle corti di Francia
e i cavalieri
si rallegrano
perché può succedere
che un cavaliere povero
venga umiliato
da un ricco borghese
ma poi
il mondo
come dire
fa giustizia
può far giustizia
in modi anche
assai più
drammatici
perché su questo
non si transige
è fondamentale
che le gerarchie sociali
vengano rispettate
a un certo punto
durante la crociata
un sergente del re
che sarebbe
come dire
diciamo
un poliziotto
oggi sostanzialmente
un dipendente
del re armato
litiga con uno
dei cavalieri
di Joinville
litiga con uno
dei cavalieri
di Joinville
e lo spintona
Joinville viene
a sapere
questa cosa
è fuori di sé
va dal re
esige giustizia
e la giustizia
lui verifica
la consuetudine
prevede
che in un caso
del genere
se un villano
si permette
di mettere la mano
addosso a un cavaliere
bisogna tagliargli
la mano
e il re
non vorrebbe
però dice
non ci si può fare niente
la consuetudine
non si applica mai
però se qui si pretende
questa è la consuetudine
e il sergente
deve venire
scalzo
in camicia
a inginocchiarsi
davanti al cavaliere
che aveva spintonato
e implorare
il suo perdono
e allungare la mano
e dire
messer cavaliere
io imploro il vostro perdono
qui c'è la mia mano
se la volete
la potete tagliare
dopodiché
tutti dicono
no va bene
d'accordo
perdoniamolo
su perdoniamolo
perdonano
lo perdonano
effettivamente
ma il principio
è stato stabilito
una volta di più
ora come si giustifica
ai loro occhi
dico
perché non si giustifica
se vogliamo
ma ai loro occhi
come si giustifica
questa idea
che i nobili
sono il sale
della terra
che i cavalieri
sono il meglio
che ci sia
e tutti gli altri
non contano niente
fondamentalmente
qui
il problema
è che i nobili
si sentono
e sono
in gran parte
quelli che fanno
la guerra
quelli che rischiano
la pelle
gli altri lavorano
fanno i soldi
ma il mestiere
del cavaliere
è rischiare la vita
il mestiere del cavaliere
per il suo signore
per i suoi compagni
d'arme
per lealtà
per la causa
per la croce
quando si va incrociata
il mestiere del cavaliere
è un mestiere duro
noi non ce ne rendiamo conto
oggi
provate a pensarci
cosa vuol dire
saper stare a cavallo
e saper galoppare
con un'armatura
di 40 chili addosso
e saper tirare
un colpo di lancia
al tuo avversario
e buttarlo giù
da cavallo
e se invece lui
beccate ti sbatte giù
da cavallo
sopravvivere a tutto questo
ed essere pronto
a ricominciare
è uno sport
durissimo
l'addestramento
dei cavalieri
uno sport estremo
in cui si lascia la pelle
facilmente
oltretutto
è uno sport
che bisogna cominciare
a praticare da bambini
un proverbio medievale
dice
uno che ha otto anni
non è ancora montato
a cavallo
ormai è buono
solo a fare il prete
se vuoi fare il cavaliere
e tenere alto
l'onore tuo
della tua famiglia
e farti rispettare
e prestare servizio
per il tuo signore
per il tuo re
devi cominciare da bambino
e andare avanti
tutta la vita
bisogna allenarsi
continuamente
e stare in guerra
significa stare lì
ore e ore
al caldo
al freddo
al gelo
con l'armatura addosso
senza niente da bere
niente da mangiare
i nobili si raccontano
queste cose
poi a dire il vero
uno va a vedere
negli eserciti
ci sarebbero anche i fantasini
i domestici
i servitori
la gente a piedi
che spesso sono quelli
che vengono ammazzati per primi
quando le cose vanno male
ma i nobili
non li vedono neanche
vedono se stessi
sui loro cavalli
con i loro elmi
Juenville è una pagina straordinaria
quando descrive
il re Luigi
che sbarca in Egitto
per primo
dalla sua galera
a cavallo
con la lancia in pugno
con l'elmo dorato
si butta in mare
che è ancora lontano
e sguazzando nel mare
sbarca
e da solo
è già pronto
dove sono i turchi?
andrebbe da solo
a caricarli
se lo lasciassero andare
ecco
questo orgoglio
del valore cavalleresco
di essere
quelli che rischiano
la vita
continuamente
per principio
per obbligo
è la cosa
che i cavalieri
sentono
giustifica
tutti i loro privilegi
poi naturalmente
ce ne sarebbero
anche altre
di cose
che dovrebbero
giustificare
i loro privilegi
naturalmente
dovrebbero essere
anche
i più beneducati
i più cortesi
i più raffinati
quelli che sanno
trattare
e in parte
è vero
perché loro
danno importanza
a queste cose
poi le scene
che racconta
Joanneville
ci fanno vedere
che spesso
la realtà
non era quella
però
quando i cavalieri
si comportano
da villani
gli altri
ci rimangono male
Joanneville
a un certo punto
racconta proprio
una vicenda così
era stato ammazzato
uno dei miei cavalieri
in combattimento
gli altri
lo vegliavano
il cadavere
sono andato lì
e li ho visti
che ridevano
perché ridete
ah niente
stavamo pensando
che adesso
bisognerà far risposare
sua moglie
e Joanneville
ci rimane malissimo
e gli dice
ma come vi permettete
il vostro camerato
è lì
ancora caldo
e voi siete lì
che scherzate
su chi si sposerà
sua moglie
vergogna
dopodiché dice
sono stati puniti
perché prima
della fine
della crociata
erano morti tutti
e tutte le loro mogli
si sono risposate
dopodiché appunto
il comportamento
con le donne
nelle camere
delle donne
come si dice
certe volte
il saper stare
con le donne
l'essere eleganti
raffinati
cortesi
questa è un'altra
caratteristica
che in questo
ambiente sociale
è valorizzata
è importante
ancora una volta
il re Luigi
si distingue
è diverso dagli altri
Joinville lo nota
il re Luigi
è uno che alle donne
non ci pensa proprio
è sposato
ma
dice Joinville
una delle cose brutte
di lui
è che con sua moglie
e con i suoi figli
praticamente
era come se fossero
estranei
e questa è una cosa
che colpisce
che non va bene
rispetto ai valori
e ai comportamenti
dei cavalieri
poi in realtà
se volessimo
vogliamo
cinque minuti
ne abbiamo ancora
il re Luigi
c'erano dei motivi
per questo
e il re Luigi
è un altro personaggio
che se uno
dovesse applicarci
un po' di psicanalisi
verrebbero fuori
delle cose interessanti
perché il re
ha perso il padre
molto giovane
ed è rimasto per anni
sotto la tutela
della madre
la regina bianca
di Castiglia
tremenda
donna di potere
che per anni
ha governato il regno
finché Luigi
era bambino
e poi quando lui
è diventato grande
l'ha preso in pugno
lui il regno
ma bianca di Castiglia
la mamma
era sempre presente
e controllava tutto
e il re
si è dovuto sposare
perché un re
si deve sposare
deve fare degli eredi
ma bianca di Castiglia
non andava d'accordo
con la nuora
e faceva di tutto
per tenerla lontana
dal marito
sono cose che racconta
Joanville sempre
cose che lui ha visto
e che a lui
non sembrano belle per niente
non riuscivano mai
a stare insieme
perché aveva sempre
la suocera
il posto
dove gli piaceva
di più vivere
in quel momento
quando erano giovani
appena sposati
era il castello
di Pontois
perché al castello
la camera del re
sta a un piano
la camera della regina
al piano di sotto
e c'è una scaletta
che le collega
e quindi
grazie a questa scaletta
il re e la regina
quando erano a Pontois
potevano stare insieme
ma tenevano
tutti e due
degli usceri
ciascuno nella sua camera
davanti alla porta
in modo che
se per caso
arrivava la regina madre
bianca
gli usceri
subito battevano
sulla porta
e il re e la regina
tornavano ciascuno
nella sua camera
perché se la suocera
gli sorprendeva insieme
succedeva una scenata
cosa succede
a un certo punto
durante la crociata
arriva dalla Francia
la notizia
che bianca di Castiglia
è morta
e Joinville
è colpito
dalle reazioni
del re
e della regina
il re
Joinville
non l'ha mai visto
così sconvolto
come quella volta
gli è arrivata
la notizia
che è morta la mamma
il re è adulto
ma è sconvolto
piange
gli va incontro
gli fa siniscalco
ho perduto mia madre
non l'ho mai visto
in quello stato
poi Joinville
va a trovare la regina
e anche la regina
piange
e siccome questa
è un'epoca
in cui appunto
i comportamenti
erano spesso spontanei
in cui spesso
non ci si censurava
si dicevano le cose
come stanno
c'era meno ipocrisia
formale
Joinville
vedendo la regina
che piange
dice ma cosa c'è da piangere
ma se era la donna
che odiavate di più al mondo
la suocera
che è morta
e infatti
la regina dice
ma non piango mica per lei
piango perché vedo
che il re è sconvolto
e ho paura
che succeda qualcosa di brutto
perché lo vedo proprio male
no no
anche a me non mi importa niente
che è morta la suocera
anzi
è gente
appunto
spesso spontanea
di una spontaneità
che a noi potrebbe anche
sembrare quasi infantile
certe volte
voi forse sapete
e forse non sapete
che nel medioevo
gli adulti giocano
giocano moltissimo
in parte sono gli stessi giochi
che facciamo noi
giocano a scacchi
giocano a dama
giocano a baggammon
giocano sempre a soldi
va detto
anche a scacchi
giocano a soldi
perché è più divertente
giocano moltissimo
ad azzardo
ad adi
anche se il re
non tollera naturalmente
e quindi
e poi giocano
a giochi che noi oggi
non facciamo più
noi adulti
cavalieri e dame
se si trovano insieme
e si annoiano
possono giocare
a mosca cieca
a nascondino
e nessuno si stupisce
perché ci si diverte
e gli adulti
non si vergognano
a divertirsi come bambini
durante la crociata
quando uno penserebbe
che avessero cose più serie
da fare
Joinville racconta
la seguente storia
eravamo lì
nell'accampamento crociato
tutte le tende
faceva bello
io e i miei cavalieri
pranzavamo davanti
alla tenda
si mette la tavola
la tovaglia bianca
nessun cavaliere
pranzerebbe mai
senza una tovaglia bianca
di bucato
è un altro simbolo
di status
i nostri cristalli
i nostri calici
pranzavamo lì
nella tenda
accanto
c'era il conte
de
il conte de
era un tipo
molto ingegnoso
pranzava anche lui
fuori dal tavolo
con i suoi cavalieri
aveva fabbricato
una piccola catapulta
e con questa piccola catapulta
dal suo tavolo
tirava delle pietre
verso il nostro
e ci fracassava
i bicchieri
e Joinville racconta
questa cosa
estasiato
quanto era simpatico
il conte de
voi immaginatevi oggi
i giochi che si fanno oggi
nei palazzi del potere
dopodiché
e qui chiudiamo
perché abbiamo fatto
quasi mezzanotte
e mi sembra
che sia arrivata
l'ora in cui ormai
il nostro cocchio
si ritrasforma in zucca
e dunque
c'è questa cultura
cavalleresca
che non tutti
sanno applicare
bisogna essere ben educati
ma non tutti ci riescono
però bisogna far vedere
che si è diversi
dai villani
si hanno tanti privilegi
ma è giusto
avere tanti privilegi
perché noi
siamo più coraggiosi
degli altri
e rischiamo la pelle
più degli altri
certe volte si esagera
la crociata è andata
a finire così male
anche perché
durante il grande attacco
che era stato deciso
contro i saraceni
il gruppo
dei cavalieri templari
doveva avere
l'avanguardia
perché spetta
per regola
in terra santa
che i templari
hanno l'avanguardia
sono i primi
ad attaccare
che è il posto d'onore
ma il fratello
del re
Roberto d'Artois
il conte d'Artois
che aveva intorno a sé
alcuni consiglieri
come dire
un po'
tracotanti
a un certo punto
l'hanno visto
che cominciava
a accelerare
e sorpassava
i templari
col suo gruppo
di cavalieri
rompendo l'ordine
che era stato prestabilito
a quel punto
i templari
vedono che il conte d'Artois
li sta sorpassando
e cominciano
a spronare anche loro
perché guai
a rimanere indietro
non si può
e tutti gli altri
dietro accelerano
anche loro
e l'intero attacco
che era stato programmato
come una successione
di interventi
di vari gruppi
di cavalieri
degenera
in una corsa sfrenata
perché nessuno
vuole avere la vergogna
di essere quello
che resta dietro
e va a finire malissimo
i turchi li circondano
il conte d'Artois
viene ucciso
quasi tutti i templari
vengono uccisi
la crociata è persa
dunque a volte
la tracotanza cavalleresca
provoca anche grossi guai
ma non sono tutti
così tracotanti
nella loro cultura
c'è un conflitto eterno
fra come dire
il culto dell'onore
del farsi vedere
del bel gesto
e la professionalità
del militare
che sa come vanno le cose
e sa che la guerra
bisogna saperla fare bene
il culto dell'onore
può servire anche
a farla bene
la guerra
ti tiene su
ti dà coraggio
nei momenti
nei momenti pericolosi
a un certo punto
durante questo
grande disastro
i cristiani
stanno scappando
si stanno ritirando
si cerca di mantenere
un po' di ordine
c'è un ponticello
che bisogna difendere
a tutti i costi
Joinville si trova
da solo
a difendere
questo ponticello
insieme con un altro
gran signore
il conte di Soasson
ci sono solo loro due
può capitare anche questo
in una guerra medievale
che due gran signori
hanno perso di vista
tutti i loro cavalieri
i loro domestici
ci sono solo loro due
a difendere questo ponticello
dietro i cristiani
che si ritirano
davanti arrivano i turchi
due cavalieri
montati bene
con delle belle armature
sono dei gran signori
hanno ottimi cavalli
spade ben affilate
ecco due cavalieri
possono essere già capaci
per qualche minuto
di fermare
tutti gli altri
che arrivano
ma chi è che si fa sotto
per primo
i saraceni si fermano
a qualche metro
e cominciano a urlare
a digregnare i denti
a gridare insulti
a tirargli pietre
comincia a similare
qualche freccia
e a questo punto
Joinville
e il conte di Soasson
si dicono
sì bene adesso li abbiamo fermati
che facciamo esattamente adesso
quelli sono lì che urlano
ma appena si muovono
e dice Joinville
il buon conte di Soasson
mi prendeva in giro
perché avevo paura
e mi diceva
siniscalco
lasciamola strillare
questa canaglia
perché per la cuffia di Dio
perché lui giurava così
dice Joinville
fra parentesi
per la cuffia di Dio
ne parleremo ancora
fra voi e me
di questa giornata
nelle camere delle dame
e questo è uno di quei casi
in cui appunto
la cultura cavalleresca
dell'onore
dell'orgoglio
ma anche dell'amor cortese
del vantarsi
ma del vantarsi
dopo aver vinto
non dopo aver perso
vinceremo
torneremo vivi
e di questa giornata
ce ne ricorderemo
e nelle camere delle dame
faremo i belli
a raccontare
le nostre avventure
e Joinville
è vissuto così a lungo
che insomma
ci è arrivato
a raccontare
le sue avventure
e un pochino
ho provato a raccontarvele
anch'io
grazie